in a fight MMA or otherwise would you
substitute anger or rage for aggression
would I substitute anger or rage for
aggressiveness is in a fight MMA or
otherwise that's important actually yeah
so we so just to clarify this means like
instead of aggression is it okay to use
anger or rage yeah okay well I think
pretty obviously and people just expect
the answer to be from me
the initial answer here is no and I
would not substitute anger or rage for
aggressiveness
I think obviously when you let rage take
over you
you're not thinking anymore yeah and the
mind is allegedly the most important
weapon and I actually believe that to be
true so if you let your rage and anger
take over you're not using your mind and
that's not good and you actually get to
see this in MMA on a fairly regular
basis because you'll get somebody that
is really good at talking smack yeah
and they'll get into the other person's
head what does it mean to get any other
person's head what does it do to them
does it make them sad no does it make
them not hate the opponent no what does
it do to them it makes them angry yes it
makes them frustrated and that anger
leads to frustration which leads to
defeat so and again I think it's
important to recognize that this doesn't
just occur in MMA it occurs in everyday
life and a good example is when you get
the conversation with something you get
into baked with somebody you get in an
argument with somebody the minute you
get frustrated or angry or enraged you
just lost the argument yeah right I mean
you might you might feel like you won
but you will not win the argument you
you lost the argument you know the
minute that that happens
yeah in any yes if it's in a debate man
because it's an understood you're
debating you're kind of against each
other and then this you just went off
the rails basically right yeah it's not
good to lose your temper in a debate in
a conversation or in an MMA match it's
like if you're playing chess we were
playing chess
and I was talking smack to you you got
frustrated and they flipped over the
chess board yeah you ain't with it with
it you know a display of monumental
power or whatever whatever those your
Ajax rage yes yeah you won't you lost no
way yeah yo you absolutely this so I
knew I talk about this all the time is
that the rule is you'd never let your
emotion get in control so you don't let
anger or rage overwhelm your little
brain now here's the here's the other
side of that coin here's the dichotomy
and I don't think you can even argue
against this hmm because it's that's
pretty sound argument right I mean what
we just said I mean we've seen it we
know we know for a fact but rules are
made to be broken
um there are times when emotion can
increase performance yeah right there
now absolutely are and I remember when I
was a kid growing up the the Soviet
Union was still just hardcore communist
and when I would watch like the Olympics
they would be like machines the Soviets
with no emotions I thought those guys
were bad
I wanted to be like that and it often
brought him victories but I heard a
quote when I was a kid and I actually
looked for it cuz I wanted to bring it
up I couldn't find it but it was
something along the lines of this and
that was that Soviet the Soviet athletes
perform better in practice but the
Americans perform better in the stadium
hmm
so the Americans and that's not a
universal statement and there's plenty
of examples of the Russians beating
Americans and whatever but there's also
examples of where the Americans with
their emotion and their fire hmm were
able to beat these Russians and I mean
the greatest example would be the
miracle of ice on ice and in Lake Placid
New York in 1980 which is you know that
was a bunch of college kids that were
fired up to beat the hardened Russian
professional hockey team yeah and and
it's because you know they kind of
trained their emotions out of it and
there's a great time to have your
emotions trained out of it you know
there's a great time where you're like
you know what I'm not gonna let my
emotions play into this I heard uh I
heard something about Tiger Woods and
his golf game and he's not thinking
about you know the the broad statement
is when he's hitting a shot in golf he's
not thinking about the last shot and
he's not thinking about the next shot
he's just thinking about that shot right
there
mm-hm so there's no emotional of whether
he's bi at or behind or nothing else
just he just is there on that one shot
so I think that you know we I think that
people I mean Americans is the example I
used but I think that people in general
can use your emotion to to your
advantage sometimes but it does take
control and it takes direction and also
I think it's important to remember that
it doesn't take long for that extra fire
of anger to go from making you stronger
and faster to making you slower and
weaker both mentally and physically so
you can get that burst and you know you
see this in fighting all the time where
people punch themselves out you know
they go they go level seven rage and
then start swinging for the first and
excitement even yeah or excitement they
think the guy they think they got the
guy in the in the her locker they come
they bring the Thunder for they get they
get emotional you know
and I think on the mat when you get a
guy that loses his temper when somebody
loses their temper with me on the mat
it's just a matter of time like I just
go okay cool he's got you know he's got
three minutes left because he's gonna be
done so yeah you've got to stay calm now
a couple situations that I've seen or
been a participant in and I'm pretty
sure I was trying to remember this for
sure but I was cornering Jeremy Stephens
and if you don't know Jeremy Stephens is
little he's an MMA awesome guy stud
fighter and we were training him at the
time and he was fighting I'm pretty sure
it was against Marcus Davis who's a
well-respected boxer really good MMA
fighter as well but definitely known for
his boxing well Jeremy's known for his
striking as well he's a very powerful
striker and he's got unbelievable one
punch knockout power Jeremy does so I
was cornering Jeremy and it was a really
really close fight I mean it was a I
didn't know if he was winning or losing
I think it was leaning towards Marcus
actually and there's three rounds in MMA
in this in this fight and in between the
second and the third round I got in the
ring got in the cage with Jeremy and I I
did the full-on you know in his face and
I know I gave him the hey listen this is
what's going on this guy across the ring
from you is taking money off your kid's
table is taking food off your kid's
table he's gonna take you the roof off
their heads he's taking everything that
you've worked for he's gonna take it
from you right now
you gotta get pissed you got to go in
there you got to destroy him and I got
you know I gotta give him a fired-up
speech like that and you could see it
switch in his eyes he realized like he
went into a rage of I need to kill this
guy yeah when he came out that round and
knocked him out yeah
and that's one I'll tell you another one
I saw that was it was the same so it was
it was Carlos Condit versus Rory
MacDonald and this was this was the
first time they fought I pretty sure it
was in Canada I was there I forget who I
was cornering but I was there and I was
done with cornered whoever's cornering
and I want to say it was Peterson boat I
was cornering I think was up in Canada
but so Carlos Condit versus Rory
MacDonald and Carlos who's the veteran
is going up gets the kid you know Rory
MacDonald wasn't kind of an he was an
unknown but he was definitely the
younger I think he was 20 years old you
know just a kid
no offense Rory but he was young you
know what I mean badass but young and
Carlos was the vet
you don't even he was a veteran grown
man with a wife and kids and man rory
was getting the better of us in front of
Rory's hometown well I don't know his
hometown but it was in Canada hmm and so
the crowd was absolutely supporting Rory
at least I'm pretty sure I remember this
right I'm sorry if I don't but it seemed
like the crowd was on the side of Rory
MacDonald hmm so in between so I'm just
watching the fight but I had snaked some
really good seats so I had a really good
few by the way when I go to UFC thanks
Dana White and the rest of the crew like
I sneak into some awesome seats after I
get done cornering people so thank you
so I was sitting you know in the second
row or something phenomenal seat that
I'd snuck into and because they throw
you the cheap seats when you're when
you're cornering people you come out to
watch the fights and yeah you're up in
the nosebleeds which isn't cool so I
just get aggressive and tactically moved
to better positions which is using the
second rail right behind the press box
so I'm sitting down there and I'm
watching the fight and Greg Jackson is
cornering Carlos Condit now if you don't
know anything about Greg Jackson he's
he's pretty zen-like a guy and I'm
actually going back in the day going way
back in the day when Dean and I were
competing all the time in the kind of
the SoCal scene of grappling we would we
do every competition there was competing
all the time
grappling how do you remember they were
there so many of them that we do and and
Greg Jackson would bring guys out to to
fight to compete and so like we wrestled
against these guys you know or we did
submission grappling against these guys
so I kind of knew him from that and then
surprisingly one time when the UFC was
in San Diego I was at work at the SEAL
Teams and someone called and said hey
there's a there's a guy from the UFC
here do you want to give him a tour of
you know he wants to tour the UFC set up
a tour of the SEAL Teams they want to
show her out mmm like the facility
facility is you know the whatever so him
some guns
you know just the gear whatever so I
show up it's Greg Jackson and you know
we kind of had a little bit of a
recognition but uh anyways Greg Jackson
and you know you kind of hear this stuff
about Greg Jackson all the time that
he's this really nice guy and that he's
super mellow and that he's really humble
well it's all freaking true he's a super
nice guy he's super humble he's just a
fantastic guy and I gave a tour and so
he kind of got to know each other and
then you know going fast forward now in
the UFC I I've I've cornered him several
times I don't know how many times I've
cornered against him you know again from
what my fighters are fighting his
fighters yeah and you know like I said
he's really like a really mellow and a
zen-like guy if you watch them in the
corners of his fights he's always like
that just very steady and hey this is
what you need to do you need to watch
out for this or whatever so I'm watching
this fight and like I said Carlos Condit
versus Rory MacDonald Carlos is not
winning right he's not winning and in
between
the second and the third round Greg
Jackson goes full Berserker mode on
content I mean he is yelling at him he
is in his face he's pointing out him
he's waving his finger he's just going
nuts on him and I was like damn Greg
Jackson is bringing the heat and sure
enough he amped up Carlos Condit Carlos
Condit came out and finished Rory in the
third Witch of a fight he was definitely
gonna lose so what you see there is
emotion helping to win in that situation
yeah and actually but when the fight was
over I saw Greg and I just kind of said
something to him you know like hey dude
you went full Berserker bogart Carlos
and he said yeah he's something like I
had to do it it is funny it's you could
see it almost seemed like he'd never got
it before I don't know maybe we'll have
to have Greg on at some point he can
tell the story but he said something
along lines of you know I I had to do it
and and it works you know he had a big
smile and that was working it and it
definitely indeed it did work yeah and
those would you do you think I mean this
total gasp but do you think that's
because those just happen to be the
exceptions or is it because really the
formula kind of seems like here's the
emotion and then here's all the logic
and the skill and the planning
implementation of you know game plans
and all that all the stuff that you're
gonna use in your in your mind and
here's the emotion it's like it's like
us a little smart plug or something and
then sure the emotion can go up but the
skill gotta go up proportionately and
once you start to do this when the
emotion takes over that's one you know
when you're gonna fail or you know take
advantage so think there's a sweet spot
in there where for moments in time
emotion and even borderlining on rage
which I think range is a little bit
strong because I think rage you lose
your clarity but anger yeah which is you
can still have some clarity of what
you're doing
right
so if I think you can actually that can
be utilized appropriately at the right
times and I think these times you know
like I talked about with Jeremy you know
I had to provoke some anger out of him
yeah you know I had to provoke and it
absolutely helped him he's gonna lose
that fight and it's the same thing with
Carlos Carlos was absolutely gonna lose
that fight if he didn't do something
different if he didn't you know it's
like it's like hitting the turbo button
it's like hitting up
nitrous oxide right it's not gonna it's
like hitting the blow the nitrous oxide
blower it's only gonna get you get me
it's only gonna make you go hard for
another yeah what is it another two
minutes or well without nitrous oxide
it's not very long at all yeah but with
but with anger you know it can make you
go for another you know whatever maybe
it's maybe it's two minutes and this is
something else have you ever missed like
a heavy single like like you okay you're
lifting you're dead lifting or you're
doing power cleans or something and you
miss a heavy signal no I never I've
heard so so this is another easy way to
prove it man I miss a heavy signal
sometimes and sometimes I just get angry
yeah it's true and I just have to bring
the anger yeah and I start getting fired
up and I start thinking about things
that make me angry yeah and I get over
that bar and I rip that thing off the
floor like I hate it yes and it
absolutely makes me stronger in that
moment so is that a dress probably
adrenaline and that's probably the same
thing that pumped into Marcus's or or
into Jeremy's head it's probably the
same thing that part pumped into
Carlos's head but it's crazy because
despite getting punched despite getting
beaten despite having someone you know
trying to destroy you in front of a
large crowd of people none of that was
able to spark the it was able to spark
the adrenaline as much as some kind of a
tap into the emotional portion of your
mind to bring out just enough rage to
get out there and get that job done once
and for all
yeah and yeah and that's really the key
there just enough for age especially
when you're talking about something that
requires technique when I say lifting
you're you're like power clean for
example and I remember
using in college and I was going for my
one rep max and yeah you fail a couple
times but for the sake of saving time
and stuff you can only give you three
times well in my case they were like you
have to get it three times
um so the first time I'd gotten all of
them I was pretty solid at power cleans
at that time so I was getting all of
them and then I got to that point and I
didn't get it it was three hundred three
hundred I weighed 185 at the time 298
are you looking for props right there
yeah okay everybody props that nobody
was talking earlier about when you name
drop and stuff yeah that's what it
sounds I did no I did that on purpose
because if I if I were to go out of my
way to leave out that number true true
you know you wanted to know you wanted
to know how much I was doing I knew
you're gonna say it it didn't matter if
Allah you wanted to know that anyway
doesn't matter
nonetheless the first time I failed and
I was like no you got this you got this
an ad and this can't even run would lose
his name oh it's pro blonde hair like
he's like he's this tough guy could hit
real hard and you would always get not
too much you got did you did you know
this and then you know making me mad or
whatever and I didn't outwardly express
any kind of anger but I felt that anger
and powerclean takes technique that's
the thing it's not like it's just um you
know like I don't know like even bench
has something but this is mrs. I mean
everything has technique brim power
clean takes a little bit more technique
than other lives yes yeah so it was just
the perfect amount of rage you know and
that's gonna depend on what kind of
person you are like Jeremy Stephens you
could tell just even the way he trains
he uses some rage in there yeah you know
as opposed to it
Rory MacDonald for example seemingly I
don't know I don't want him trained long
time or nothing but it seems like he's
super methodical you know in rage or
anger whatever is it is as much of a
part as someone like to measure me fight
with Robbie Lawler yeah yeah what is he
bored adjusted Yemen yeah
the way they train up there at tristar's
I spent like the the weekend or was like
half a week or whatever with them with
Fras and um and Rory and it's Frost has
this head you know how guys will hold
mitts I'm sure they hold mitts and stuff
but he has this head that you hit the
head instead of the mitts
so it seems like oh that's not that like
it seems kind of obvious so I never seen
no one do that and it made way more
sense because I've hit mitts before and
then when you go to spar it's like it's
kind of weird you gotta get used to the
difference between hitting mitts and
heating someone's head so I got these
guys kids are smart up here in game yeah
yeah respect to those guy mean I would
respect all the guys that get into that
getting the UFC and fight man it's
awesome to watch and that that Lawler
McDonald fight was just uh was just
insane it was insane you just watch that
fight if you have anyone that hasn't
watched that fight go watch that fight
if you wanna see a couple warriors just
Brianna bringing it off and leaving it
all right there and again you go watch
that fight so did you get the power to
clean I got the power clean yes yes and
then here's the thing about that power
clean isn't so you I yeah I got it right
and so you go up okay you gotta you go
up in weight to the next one it was like
303 like super small weight yeah yeah
just so you can get the 303
not even close everything was spent on
that that you name is that one didn't we
was that the all time life life nah I
just disengaged that's all that was just
engaged I see where it's at